mir hat das von kinder schon
interessiert mich auch gern
modellflieger gebaut ich habe mir gerne
angeschaut
ob das aber nachher nicht wirklich in
meiner schulzeit weiter verfolgt sondern
erst beim bundesheer hat man mir die
option offen gelegt dass man sich dafür
melden kann man habe lacht ja wenn es
jetzt nicht macht dann wird
wahrscheinlich nie passieren war der
erste flug einfach wahnsinn die
geschwindigkeit gesteigerten seien
unbeschreiblich es war bei seiner
strecken chrome mit knapp 300 km h und
dieses eindrucksvolle und
unbeschreiblichen erlebten
die ausbildung ja in anfänglichen
theorie teil relativ leeren intensiv
dann während der praktischen teil ist es
weniger lernen sondern einfacher
flugvorbereitung das orientieren dass
das handling von flieger das geht man
halt alles vorher im kopf durch auch am
tag vorher am abend denkt muss eine
bibel zu sein wir wollen in vielen statt
auf einmal das ganze mit einer
freiwilligen meldung bezüglich zum
piloten dann kommt man zwei wochen lang
ein sehr rasch betreut wird der fährt
zum hier getestet einmal die zwei wochen
gestanden hat kann man zwei monate nach
zeltweg dort wird man dann laufen
peter übung bewertet und am info d2
monat wird gesagt wenn jemand ihre
nehmen wenn irgendwelche fragen gehabt
habe die ist wo ich selber nicht drauf
gekommen bin dann immer irgendwie damit
in die ohren hat keinen direktor so war
es bei ihnen damals oder so kann es mal
versuchen und da gibt es immer so
feinheiten die man außerhalb der
schulung auch wirklich durch gespräch
dann mit bekommt von den von den älteren
von denen die einfach dass so viel
länger nach
natürlich eurofighter gelobt werden
womöglich ganz gut dabei bin jetzt
bereit natürlich den nächsten schritt
auf der b 105 1 belohnt werden wie mache
jetzt meine fortgeschrittenen ausbildung
hat das ab 15
daraufhin wird vermutlich irgendwann die
umschulung auf den eurofighter anstehen